[Applause]
funeral services for three of the five
young men shot and killed by security
forces in Nuevo Laredo Mexico last
Sunday
autopsy reports obtained by the Spanish
newspaper El Pais now reveal disturbing
new details
such as military personnel firing more
than 60 rounds and from multiple angles
what we know is that the military
discharges their weapons without prior
provocation from anyone what's clear is
that not a single protocol was followed
and people were killed without having
done anything this should be part of the
investigation
the shooting incident gained attention
after this amateur video appearing to
show soldiers discharging their firearms
to disperse a crowd after the incident
went viral on social media
the outrage has only intensified after
21 year old Alejandro Perez a survivor
of the attack hold investigators that
soldiers may have tried to cover up
their actions
in fact the soldier asked me if I wanted
to leave and I told him yes I do want to
leave then he said now we're going to
record a video where you told this is
what's all your fault that you were
fleeing which isn't the truth the deadly
incident in Nuevo Laredo has sparked
anger in Mexico and led to calls for
accountability and accusations of
corruption within Mexico's security
apparatus
some say this latest attack against
unarmed civilians follows a troubling
pattern among security forces in Nuevo
Laredo
it's important to note that at any time
there is an action like this where the
army or the Marines make a mistake they
react by criminalizing the victims to
make them appear as spies Killers or
parts of some criminal organization
Mexico's president Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador has promised an investigation
will be forthcoming adding that his
government is committed to protecting
human rights
we've asked for intervention from the
national Human Rights Commission to
investigate this case also military
authorities are also helping with the
investigation
as details continue to emerge over what
really happened in Nuevo Laredo early
reports suggest that security forces
mistakenly identified the young men as
criminal suspects though questions
remain over why soldiers ultimately
decided to engage with lethal Force
Al Jazeera Mexico City